ce soir vous avez été incroyable concert
- est fait kiffer à mort
[Musique]
éviter de lancer notre label on en est
et va s'appeler apache musicale
maintenant faut comprendre faire est ce
que vous êtes déjà chaud sur des
artistes on cherche nos premières
signatures
neuf meilleurs qu'à majorité nomique
encore
tu es sur les réseaux sous qui est
repris par les plus group ni droit
français maintenant ça va pas du tout
j'ai pas envie de raconter ma vie mais
c'est pas pour rien que j'arrêtais le
pompier moi sinon je veux nique et
apache musique et j'ai besoin d'être
pour ça
brême ne remet pas dans les environs pas
besoin mais ouvre les yeux on est déjà
mort ils ont trouvé charmant la
surmonter